nous sommes dans la zone commerciale de
sarran et l'enseigne s'impose au regard
superficie mille mètres carrés environ
et douze mille produits références si
les produits sont 100 % bio la part des
producteurs locaux réduisent comme peau
de chagrin d'où cet appel pressant du
pied
on travaille avec une dizaine de
producteurs locaux donc issu du loiret
et de la région centre
on a vocation bien évidemment à
développer autant que possible les
circuits courts c'est très important
pour nous effectivement on fait un appel
voilà au aux producteurs qui serait dans
le coin et il serait intéressé de
rejoindre les comptoirs de la bio à sa
rencontre travaillent effectivement
aussi avec des entreprises qui sont
situés à des milliers de kilomètres par
exemple pour certains fruits ou légumes
qu'ils ne peuvent pas être produits en
france je pense par exemple à la banane
la papaye qu'on peut retrouver
d'amérique du sud ou bien de l'outre-mer
martini guadeloupe par exemple au rayon
des fruits et légumes les producteurs
locaux brillent par leur absence à leur
décharge ce magasin s'approvisionne
auprès d'une centrale d'achat pour
comprimer ses primes est ce que vous
avez trouvé des producteurs locaux
locaux
non
[Musique]
un manque un peu ouais c'est dommage
c'est dommage mais je pense que ça va
venir je le souhaite à défaut de
circuits courts les clients scrute le
made in france on dit français grâce à
ça me plaît ça
au point de vue grain au point de vue
céréales tout ça je il ya du choix quand
même il ya beaucoup de choix c'est bien
qu'on est il du prix
sar ça vaut le savon le bio en grandes
surfaces ouais c'est bien et qu'on est
il des produits locaux des producteurs
locaux bah y'a pas grand chose le bio a
longtemps été un marché de niche
désormais et s'affiche en grand un très
grand alors